HERE AT THE "THE
DAILY SHOW" WE DON'T JUST
BELIEVE IN AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
WE CELEBRATE IT WITH AN ANNUAL
AWARD HONORING THE NEWS STORY
THAT BEST ENCOMPASSES OUR
COUNTRY'S PURE ESSENCE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I GIVE YOU
THE 2015 'MERCUN AWARDS.
( LAUGHTER )
HERE TO HELP SELECT A WINNER ARE
OUR AMERICAN JUDGES,
SAMANTHA BEE, AND
JESSICA WILLIAMS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THANK YOU, YES, IT'S GOOD TO BE
HERE.
>> I'M CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED.
>> Jon: SETTLE DOWN.
>> YES, THAT'S TRUE.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT, JUDGES, THE
FIRST AMERICAN FINALIST COMES TO
US FROM PITTSBURGH,
PENNSYLVANIA.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> PANIC AT AN EASTER VIGIL
MASS.
A MAN BRINGS A GUN INTO A CHURCH
AND IT GOES OFF,.
>> THE TRIGGER CAUGHT ON THE
MAN'S PANTS.
>> Jon: FIREARM TROUSER
MISHAP AT A CHURCH,
JUDGES WHAT, DO YOU SAY?
>> OKAY, WELL, IT'S GOOD.
IT'S GOT THE INGREDIENTS OF AN
'MERCUN-WORTHY STORY, DEVOUT
RELIGIOSITY PAIRED WITH
GUN-TOTING PARANOIA,
VERY AMERICAN.
BUT I FEEL LIKE HE COULD HAVE
TRIED HARDER.
I MEAN, IF HE'D DONE IT WHILE
WEARING FLIP-FLOPS AND
A SLEEVELESS CREEDENCE SHIRT,
I'D HAVE KNOWN HE WANTED IT.
SO, I'M GOING TO GIVE THIS STORY
ONE BASEBALL-SHAPED TWINKIE.
>> Jon: THAT'S A SOLID
SCORE.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: JESSICA, YOUR SCORE.
>> YEAH, I FELT IT NEEDED AN
EXTRA EDGE.
'MERCUN WINNER SHOULD MAKE ME
FEEL LIKE SUPERMAN IS THROWING A
HAMBURGER AT MY FACE WHILE
SHOTGUNNING A MOUNTAIN DEW WITH
BETSY ROSS, SO I'M GOING TO GIVE
THIS ONE,
ONE AND A HALF TRUCK NUTS.
>> Jon: OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
NOT, THAT'S NOT TERRIBLE.
I GOTTA SAY.
BY THE WAY, THAT IS ONE AND A
HALF OUT OF--
>> HOW MANY NUTS DO YOU HAVE,
JON?
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT, SO OUT
OF THREE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Jon: MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT
FINALIST.
THIS STORY IS FROM GEORGIA.
>> A MAN SHOT AN ARMADILLO BUT
ENDED UP ACCIDENTALLY WOUNDING
HIS MOTHER-IN-LAW.
THE BULLET BOUNCED OFF THE
ARMADILLO, HIT A FENCE, TRAVELED
THROUGH THE BACK DOOR OF HIS
MOTHER-IN-LAW'S MOBILE HOME 100
YARDS AWAY.
IT PIERCEDLY THE RECLINER
SHE WAS SITTING IN BEFORE
FINALLY STRIKING HER IN THE
BACK.
NO CHARGES EXPECTED TO BE FILED.
( LAUGHTER )
>> WELL, I SHOULD HOPE NOT.
>> YEAH, IF A MAN CAN'T GET AWAY
WITH PLUGGING HIS MOTHER-IN-LAW
IN THE BACK THROUGH THE WALL OF
HER TRAILER AND THEN BLAMING A
DEAD VARMINT, WE MIGHT AS WELL
TAKE THE CONSTITUTION AND
JUST FLUSH IT DOWN THE TOILET.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE DAMN STRAIGHT.
THAT BULLET COULDN'T HAVE TAKEN
MORE OF AN AMERICAN JOURNEY IF
IT HAD PUNCTURED A KRAFT SINGLE,
RICOCHETED OFF A NASCAR TROPHY
AND GOT LODGED AT A PAINTING OF
ELVIS AND JESUS HOLDING HANDS AT
A RODEO.
>> I'M GIVING THIS ONE A BEN
FRANKLIN WEARING AN AMERICAN
FLAG BIKINI WHILE EATING A KFC
DOUBLE DOWN.
>> Jon: THAT'S A NEARLY PERFECT
SCORE.
A NEARLY PERFECT SCORE!
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jon: UNBELIEVABLE! SAM?
>> I DO, I DO AGREE WITH
JESSICA.
I GIVE IT A WASHINGTON HOLDING
REAGAN'S LEGS WHILE HE DOES A
KEG STAND ON THE LIBERTY BELL.
>> Jon: WOW, THAT'S JUST, THAT'S
AMAZING.
>> JON, YEAH --
>> Jon: THAT'S AMAZING.
>> JON, LET'S JUST GIVE
ARMADILLO SHOOTER THE 'MERCUN
NOW AND THEN LET'S ALL GO
CELEBRATE WITH BUD LIGHT
INFUSED JALAPENO POPPERS AT GUY
FIERI'S AMERICAN KITCHEN.
>> Jon: NOW, NOW NOT SO FAST
THOUGH.
THERE'S ONE FINAL ENTRY FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF NEW JERSEY.
>> A NEW JERSEY COURT SAYS A MAN
CANNOT SUE APPLEBEE'S
NEIGHBORHOOD BAR AND GRILL OVER
CLAIMS HE SUFFERED BURNS WHILE
PRAYING AT DINNER.
>> THE MAN CLAIMED A WAITRESS
DIDN'T WARN HIM THAT HIS
SIZZLING STAKE FAJITA
SKILLET WAS HOT.
♪ BURNED IN THE U.S.A. ♪♪
>> WOW, THAT HAD EVERYTHING.
IT HAD PUBLIC PRAYER.
>> FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION.
>> A FAMILY CHAIN RESTAURANT
SERVING FAKE MEXICAN FOOD.
>> NOT KNOWING THAT A SIZZLING
GRIDDLE OF STEAK MIGHT BE HOT.
>> I LOVE THIS COUNTRY SO MUCH.
I'M GOING TO DO IT.
I'M GIVING IT THE FULL TWO-GUNS
( BLEEP ) EACH OTHER.
>> Jon: WOW!
WOW!
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE.
AMAZING.
JESS WHAT WHAT WHATDO YOU SAY?
>> HELLS YEAH, I'M GOING WITH
LADY LIBERTY DRIVING A MONSTER
TRUCK WITH PIZZA WHEELS
ON TOP OF MOUNT RUSHMORE.
>> Jon: TWO PERFECT SCORES! WE
HAVE A WINNER.
THE 2015 'MURICAN GOES TO
LITIGIOUS PRAYING
APPLEBEE'S BURN VICTIM.
CONGRATULATIONSES AND GOD BLESS.